the NHS is in crisis staff say they're
at breaking point but many feel unable
to raise their concerns
at the start of this year we set up an
email address asking for your stories
from the NHS front line since then we've
had hundreds of messages many of them
with harrowing details but we were
struck by the sheer volume of emails
that mentioned fears of speaking up not
just to us as a national broadcaster but
also internally within the NHS
without doubt people are too scared to
whistleblow or believe that there's
nothing that can be done
I've always been scared to speak up but
we need to get some real stories out
there please keep me Anonymous as I'm
scared of repercussions nurses are
always under fear of speaking out
sorry to remain anonymous but I wouldn't
trust my employer to treat me fairly for
exposing info that should be in the
public domain and we're not alone
whistleblowing charity protect told us
that in the last year 77 percent of NHS
workers who called their helpline
reported retaliation as a result of
speaking up and 33 percent said they
were either dismissed or felt they had
to resign after doing so
John not his real name is a paramedic in
the south of England his experience is
typical
if you speak up you'll be penalized one
way or another and it will harm your
career if you're a junior doctor and you
speak out about something you're
probably going to remain a junior doctor
and the same stands for our guys in the
ambulance crew
in 2015 a government commissioned review
Into the NHS culture of Silence
recommended the creation of a network of
freedom to speak up Guardians across the
organization Jane chegy Clark is the
national Guardian for England everyone
comes to work to do a good job and that
includes speaking up when something
doesn't feel right that can invert
patient harm or can be an improvement to
the service and I think at the moment
there's lots of good work being done in
organizations to improve the speak up
culture but sadly in some there is still
an absolute fear of repercussions
NHS England told us in a statement that
the NHS is committed to creating a
positive work environment and it's
completely unacceptable for any member
of staff to feel silenced
it's no secret the NHS has many problems
tackling its culture of secrecy would be
one way to start addressing them Matthew
Thompson Sky News